the unofficial kickoff to summer is this
weekend which means lots of outdoor fun
for families that's right dirt bikes
atvs rovs or just hiking it's all fun
but it's important to ride those
machines responsibly bianca holman is
live this morning getting her atv game
going bianca good morning to you
hey good morning john good morning
heather so these off-road vehicles they
really became popular during the
pandemic it's hard to find one in stores
now because they're so popular and we're
i we live in an ideal space for this
right i'm joined by andrea you who is a
atv instructor yeah there's more than
like there's nearly 20 different riding
trails just in clark county alone so if
you go to
nv.ohv.gov you can find plenty of places
to ride so once you have your atv once
you have your dirt bike we got some
important gear that you need to wear so
tell us about what we have here
absolutely gear up every ride head to
toe so you want your helmet goggles
gloves if you can you get a chest
protector elbow protector you want to
have long sleeve shirt and long pants
and then over the ankle boots to protect
every part of your body now what can
happen if people go out there in sandals
and not wear a helmet or go out there
you know not wearing this gear oh my
gosh yeah you could definitely get more
injuries that way but definitely gear up
every ride you know you don't want to
get hit by brush or rocks or you know
even
just like things bugs bugs i don't like
a little bit of everything and also
there are classes once people have these
bikes you want to take them out but you
want to make sure that your kid has
training that you have training tell us
about the importance of training
absolutely there are certain skills that
you need to use for off-road riding
whether you're on dirt bikes or atvs or
even on those side by sides so these
classes if you buy a brand new atv you
could probably get a free class so go to
atvsafety.org to find that and then
there's dirtbikeschool.org but also what
we talk about too is before you ride you
want to do a pre-ride inspection and
because did you know you can ride
farther in one hour than you can walk in
a day so you want to make sure your
equipment is ready to go before you head
out you don't want to be stranded out
there
definitely not well again great tips we
know lots of people are going to be
headed out to the trails again that
safety gear getting into a training
class all important because you won't
definitely want to have fun out there
and of course protect our wildlife
that's out there so that's another
reason why it's important to make sure
that you're equipped and you know what
you're doing so i'm going to send it
back to you guys in the studio bianca
thank you very much they call it go
faster gear the gear is cool i love the
helmets the gloves you look awesome so
cool and so important speaking of cool
gear